new york city with a strict new policy
to fight covet that could set an example
for other cities in a move that he calls
a preemptive strike mayor bill de blasio
has announced that all private sector
workers in this city should have at
least one dose of a coveted vaccine by
december 27th that's less than three
weeks from now 60 percent of all u.s
citizens are now fully vaccinated but
the cases we're sorry to say are still
rising mostly in those who do not have
the shot nikki batista is here with more
on new york city's new rules nikki good
to see you good morning gail good
morning mayor de blasio says he made the
first in the nation move to help curb
the spike in cases brought on by omicron
in the winter months he says he will
explain how the new mandate will be
enforced and any consequences for any
private sector workers who refuse a
vaccine on december 15th
we need to take very bold action
aggressive action to address these new
threats new york city mayor bill de
blasio announced the new mandate for
private employers monday impacting about
184 000 businesses there is no testing
alternative but those working remotely
will not be required to get the shot the
order also mandates kids as young as
five to have one dose of the vaccine
before they can go inside restaurants
and entertainment venues starting next
week this is how we put health and
safety first this comes as the biden
administration's new travel requirements
take effect for those flying back to the
u.s they must test negative for kovid
within 24 hours of their flight while
the delta variant makes up the vast
majority of the more than 100 000 new
daily covet cases in the u.s the omicron
variant is spreading rapidly as many as
20 states have confirmed at least one
case in the last few days in louisiana
at least 17 coveted cases were
discovered on a norwegian cruise line
ship that returned to port sunday a
south african crew member is suspected
of testing positive for the omicron
variant passengers all of whom were
fully vaccinated say they had no clue we
were tested on saturday but we didn't
know anything about
any kind of outbreak on board ship we
heard when we got to port and had cell
phone service and saw the news early
data shows those with the omicron
variant have mild symptoms but so much
is still unknown we'll see how the
omicron variant accelerates in the
coming weeks dr peter hotes says the
focus needs to remain on vaccinations we
still have too many people who are
either unvaccinated or under vaccinated
and that's a killer
a norwegian cruise line spokesperson
told us the health and safety of its
guests and crew are its highest priority
dr hota says he believes that covid
vaccines will likely offer some
protection against the omicron variant
but he says we'll know more in the days
and weeks ahead as we get more data nate
nikki thank you